hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's now this is the Halloween
update to the game which means that
there's a lot new content to explore how
much I don't exactly know but we can
look in the extra menu and we can see
that there's new features that have been
added some very creepy some disturbing
some I won't show you all of because I
kind of want to keep something secret
for myself so in the animatronics you
can see that there's now Jack o Bonnie
and Jack Oh chica and there's a few more
but I haven't explored that because I
kind of want to find that out in the
game there's nothing new here but there
is something new in the jump-scares menu
nightmare mangle has been added to the
game and also there's new cheats there's
new challenges which seem obscenely hard
there's blind bode which I can only
imagine you go through the whole game
without being able to see anything and
have to listen to all the doors and
whatnot there's mad Freddie which we can
only imagine insta foxy I imagine he
appears there at the beginning of the
game and all nightmare mode which is
probably the new 2020 2020 mode and also
there's fun with Balloon Boy and holy
crap Balloon Boy does not look fun so
we've got a lot to explore but first I
want to actually go into the main game
start a new game and actually see if
there's something
story-wise that's been developed because
there still is the mystery of the box
like there's still the box in there
somewhere and I don't know where the box
fits into everything hello little guy
and I mean we've all seen the theory
videos probably what did he do this time
I don't know he locked me every room I
Birdman but if I know Scott and I
I don't know Scott but if I know how he
makes his games he probably added in
something secret to find out in the main
game now if there's nothing else for me
to find while I'm playing the main game
I will only show you new content I'm not
gonna waste your time and just do a
whole new play through the whole game I
want to show you the new stuff I want to
get to the new stuff I'm super excited
about the new stuff and I am excited to
be scared again I got my lucky flannel
and everything I'm ready to reclaim my
clown crown crown crown rate I have my
clown Larry Larry
yeah get out here is Larry okay go away
now hmm that's the first night they're
never that bad on the first night
there's no way I'm gonna die on the
first night chuckle Oh someone's orange
and glowy who was that Jackie Loni
oh oh whoa oh I forgot I'm okay now I
gotta listen now I gotta get back into
the listen mode where I just suddenly
stop talking
random intervals for no reason Oh miss
it's like I know this wasn't that long
ago but memories you know this was like
a big part of my life I dedicated many
brain cells to this many many brain
cells to this repetitive action whoa hey
how's it going there buddy
oh it's so cool hey there we go I did it
oh boy Hawaii I really wonder did anyone
decode those numbers to actually mean
anything because if they did oh you're
good
I have no idea hey but oh look oh there
is stuff all in the house Jack O'Lantern
in the house I knew there was gonna be
stuff oh man there's mangle I knew there
was a reason that mango was in here
there had to be a reason even though
mango wasn't really a thing until this
second five nights at freddys over there
over where over there over where are you
pointing at something there's something
in here there are sacred Terra secret
what's in the box what's in the box
hello boo boo oh geez huh hi how's it
going
Mauro's another day okay so it makes
sense it makes sense fun with blue oh my
god it's gonna make me play fun with
Balloon Boy I'm not okay on this okay
all right I'm not okay with this all
right I'm ready
come on Balloon Boy you creepy bastard
uh you're so weird oh my god don't do
that to me
huh hi don't say hi
cool okay and then slow mom oh god damn
it
uh-huh [ __ ] me ah Balloon Boy you
bastard you bastard bar [ __ ] [ __ ] you
whoo okay all right
so what I'm gonna do is um because
obviously this would take a long time
for me to play through the game normally
what I'm gonna do is I'm actually going
to right now for this episode here I'm
going to well first what it
okay so I've decided um what I'm gonna
have to do is I'm gonna have to play
through the entire game again on my own
while I'm recording of course and then I
will piece together everything new that
I find for the next episode but for this
one I really kind of want to take on a
little bit of these challenges here I
don't think I'm gonna be able to beat
him because I'm still a little rusty
from the game but I can only imagine
what he'll all nightmare mode will
unleash so why not go oh my oh I thought
oh okay oh I could do that I don't want
to do that blind mode whole nightmare no
thank you I'll just do all nightmare
mode thank you how do i how do I go how
do I go how do I go I think I got a play
fun with Balloon Boy before I get
started on that one because I can get a
bonus hour if I get Balloon Boy on the
spot so if I can do that I get a little
bit of extra for my all nightmare mode
this is gonna be horrible this is gonna
be the worst I'm gonna do so bad I'm
gonna die
Oh in so many ways ha ah I almost got
you on that one
come on get on the spot [ __ ] god damn it
oh you suck blows right there who's
right on top of the play ah come on oh
sorry to challenge beau dear
Oh maybe all nightmare nightmare mode Oh
that'll be fun Oh that'll be good
oh boy I can't waver is all more if I
have to beat night 7 again what no no no
no no no oh no no no no no you didn't
tell me the baby was back of the
marionette the marionettes back
why is marionette back why did I do what
could I have done what what okay I
shouldn't play that mode I'm not
emotionally ready there's new concept my
crown is abandoned my flannel is coming
off wait no that's nope that's dope yo
dope all right so that was terrible I
think I need to play through the game
again because I didn't know the merry
you know is gonna be a part of this or
the baby I call him the baby about about
try selling these cheats just it'll be
it'll only be on night two I'm not gonna
do it for an important night but I I
can't adjust want to see Oh a new game
god damn it I
ah I still left all nightmare mode on oh
no oh no no no no oh no oh no oh no oh I
don't know what the map means I don't
wait how do I stop the marionette what
do I do
is there something on my bed how do I
stop it I don't know it hasn't taught me
I'm so dead okay let me just let me turn
that let me turn that off and turn that
off let me turn that off
let me turn let turn that off yeah over
turn that off yeah what the hell
what is that baloney this is not like
fun with bud trap it's not fun it's not
fun with Balloon Boy okay I want to get
through the second night I really want
to get through the second night by
myself I've got no cheats activated I'm
ready to rock because if there's a new
animatronic here I mean hello hi I'm
getting started really early aren't you
hey buddy you are getting started early
it's a bit more hectic night too than I
thought okay
all right I feel so vulnerable without
cheats the nights are dark and full of
terrors
this night is hellishly long okay what
was that
chickens in the kitchen with bond hey oh
hey hey
well heard that what was that
hi what is that why is this is mango
crawling on the ceiling can mingle do
that Bengal does that mangle do that I
know mangle do God I didn't hear the
breathing oh come on no it's the second
night I'm so bad ah ah piss alright
that's enough for that's enough for this
one I've explored a lot of territory
here and I don't know how to beat it
it's all new so I'll figure this out in
the next episode thank you everybody so
much for watching check out all the
other cool five nights at Freddy's stuff
animations compilations other videos
other games that I played in the
description below in the annotations
over there thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you
in the next video
you know I feel a deeper connection
looking at ya